what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today it looks like we have a ton of
news of what could possibly happen in
the Fantastic Four film as well as who
could be the actual cast including who
could be playing Dr Doom and Galactus
and the Silver Surfer which is truly
exciting because we know that a Silver
Surfer special presentation is coming
pretty soon and Galactus is supposedly
going to appear or at least be hinted at
in the Fantastic Four film so there's a
lot to dive into today so let's just
jump right into it now first and
foremost if you haven't heard the
reports we are supposed to be getting
the Silver Surfer in the MCU before the
Fantastic Four movie like I mentioned it
is most likely going to be a special
presentation according to the most
recent reports from some insiders these
reports also state that Galactus is
supposed to appear in the MCU before
phase 7. and these reports do state that
he isn't exactly going to be a big bad
in the MCU before phase 7. so make no
mistake even though Galactus could come
to the MCU in the Multiverse Saga Kang
the Conqueror is the big bad of the
Multiverse Saga nobody else now there
might be some other villains but they
won't take the main Spotlight in fact in
this video we'll talk about two villains
who will be a part of the Multiverse
Saga but will be big bads in the next
Saga but first let's go into the casting
news that we've recently heard now
here's the deal these leaks are coming
from 4chan so they are posted
anonymously supposedly from some Insider
that has heard a lot about the casting
for the fantastic form that includes the
villains and even though this is
extremely interesting take it with a
grain of salt because it hasn't been
officially confirmed yet so right off
the bat it says John Krasinski is not
Reed Richards in the MCU not the main
one at least in the Fantastic Four film
that is coming because of course we've
already seen Reed Richards in the MCU
and this doesn't come as too big of a
surprise we already knew this we knew
that Kevin really threw John Krasinski
as Reed Richards into Multiverse of
Madness for fan service in an interview
about the movie he pretty much stated
that outright he thought it would be fun
because the fans were all casting him as
read and it was cool however that read
doesn't really matter to the MCU at all
especially now because he's dead now
there are two names that have been
thrown around a lot for the casting of
Reed Richards and you probably have
heard these reports slash rumors these
names are Ryan Gosling and Adam Driver
now Ryan Gosling's name has been thrown
out there for a little bit now it's
clear that he met with Marvel Studios at
this point however there are multiple
reports stating that he's been cast for
very different roles some have been
Sentry some have been Reed Richards of
course however this report says that he
is in talks to play the Silver Surfer
now like always when I mentioned
somebody is in the running to be a
certain character in the MCU I want to
know your thoughts so right away let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below now as far as what
he would sound like he would definitely
have to be talking in a very bomb
demeanor but of course be able to take
it up a notch when he fights which Ryan
Gosling is perfectly capable of doing
and as far as the figure is concerned we
know that Ryan Gosling can get super
ripped he's done it plenty of times in
fact right now he should already be
super ripped because he's playing kin in
the Barbie movie now this leak says that
Silver Surfer was originally a part of
the Fantastic Four movie Draft but is
unsure on whether or not the Silver
Surfer will be in the actual film but
this does go on to say that Gosling if
he signs will appear as the Silver
Surfer in a special presentation so
further backing up what we've already
heard now the next two names for
Galactus and Dr Doom I must say I
actually really like and we'll start
with doom you may have heard Adam
driver's name for Reed Richards but
apparently he's in the running to play
Doctor Doom and I can already see this
now I already see kylo Ren without the
face mask on with the hood over him
looking like Doom just changed his cloak
to green and I can really see Adam
Driver as Doom I really really loved him
as kylo Ren I think a lot of people did
and I think if he brought that same
energy to the role he would make an
Incredible Dr Doom this also does back
up some reports that we've heard from
some other insiders I believe Grace
Randolph was the first person to say
that Disney was eyeing some actors from
the Star Wars franchise to appear in the
Fantastic Four and of course since both
lucasfilm and Marvel Studios are owned
by Disney it makes it really easy to
kind of meet with actors and talk to
them about roles but also at the same
time keeping it within the Disney family
so I actually think that there could be
a pretty decent chance that this could
happen so of course let us know what you
think about it in the comments down
below now as far as the casting for
Galactus goes there are two names that
are mentioned here one is all right but
one I must say I would really love to
see happen the first name mentioned is
Dennis Quaid and although I am an
extremely big fan of the work that he's
done in film and on TV I'm not so sure
how I feel about this I feel like I
would prefer somebody like Liam
especially as far as the voice for
Galactus goes now we're unsure at this
point in time if Galactus is going to be
CGI and simply these actors are going to
voice Galactus but I think it makes
sense for the actor to actually portray
Galactus and have the face of the actor
so I'm a little on the fence about this
however the other name I would be really
excited for and it is Keanu Reeves one I
think his voice would sue Galactus very
well it wouldn't exactly be like we've
heard so far from video games and from
animated series but I think his voice
would suit Galactus very very well I'd
also love to see him physically act as
Galactus as well because remember
Galactus isn't necessarily bad in fact
eternity the cosmic entity said that he
was a necessary part of the universe and
that he actually provides balance now
I'm sure he'll be depicted as evil in
whatever movie he appears in because of
course he's most likely going to be
coming to devour Earth so that would
make him a bad guy to everybody on Earth
and according to this report he could be
the main villain of the Fantastic Four
film which makes perfect sense he is an
iconic Fantastic Four villain but so is
Dr Doom however the last three Fantastic
Four films that we got from Fox had
Doctor Doom as the villain and yes one
of them had the Silver Surfer and
Galactus but we don't really count that
Galactus because it really wasn't
Galactus so due to that fact Kevin feige
might want to stay away from having Dr
Doom be the main villain of the new
Fantastic Four film and have Galactus be
the main villain and I'm all for this
because I actually think that Dr Doom
would make a better big bad villain than
Galactus actually would because Galactus
kind of just has one purpose he sets out
to devour planets he has his Heralds
that scout out planets that would be
good for him to devour and that's his
thing and honestly it's epic but it's
quick at least when it comes to Earth
and I really like what they're doing
with King now having him appear in
multiple films and TV shows before he
finally arrives for his big movies
Thanos was great but he was kind of just
teased throughout the entire Infinity
Saga and then he appeared in the last
two films if they went with Galactus it
would probably have to be like that
showing him kind of coming to Earth and
then eventually arriving at Earth
however there is so much to Dr Doom he
is one of the most powerful Sorcerers
that have ever been in Marvel history
plus he has major ties to the Fantastic
Four also the Avengers and he also has a
link to Kang in fact Kang's armor in the
comics is based off of Dr Doom's armor
who he is believed to be a descendant of
in the comics depending on which story
you follow he can also interact a lot
more with the people on Earth and with
the different superhero teams than
Galactus could which is why I think he
would be much better suited to play a
big bad of an entire Saga rather than
Galactus although I'm excited to see
both of them now one of the last things
that it says is the Fantastic Four
members are going to be in their 30s
minus Johnny AKA The Human Torch who
will be in his 20s and this makes
perfect sense because Johnny is the
younger brother of Sue storm AKA The
Invisible Woman and this kind of lines
up with what Kevin feige told us about
the Fantastic Four stating it's not
really going to be a true origin story
so if they do show us the Fantastic Four
who are a little bit down the line
already it would make sense that they
would be kind of older and I personally
would like to see an older Fantastic
Four because Reed Richards is the
smartest man alive and I'd like to see
him grown up and mature but let us know
what you think about this in the
comments down below and also just let us
know what you think about the overall
casting names that are thrown out there
for many different characters of the
Fantastic Four so let us know your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe stay up to date
on the latest in the MCU for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf wolf
foreign